all right guys
bang bang i've got alex here with me
what's going on man what's up man
how are you uh no voice left so i don't
know how i'm gonna do this
uh we're talking shortly after uh pretty
big news
of el salvador in about a four-day
period went from
uh announcing that they were going to uh
create
bitcoin as legal tender uh with nina's
or within el salvador
um or accept it as legal tender then
they
basically put forward a bill they voted
on it
they passed it it's now legal tender the
president jumps on twitter spaces
he's talking about all kinds of stuff
answering questions like super candid
uh seemed like a pretty like open book
at some point mining comes up he's like
ah well we have this like volcano
uh volcanic energy that is 100 renewable
100 clean
zero emission uh and basically free
maybe we could use that for mining
24 hours later he's literally already
drilled the well and like seems like
he's off to the races
what the hell is going on now this is i
mean el salvador and bitcoin it's like
the
the this space moves so fast it's like
two weeks ago
the pope was like we can't use bitcoin
like two weeks later we've got a country
putting some bitcoin
like talk me through like from what i
understood
it's they're going to so they've made it
legal tender
people who don't want to hold bitcoin
they can actually sell it back to the
government so the
government's gonna hold the bitcoin and
give them fiat is that right so
uh in el salvador and again this is a
over generalization
but there's basically two banks that
you're gonna hear about you hear about
the central bank
right or or kind of the the state
balance sheet that reserves because they
technically don't have
they don't have their own currency uh so
there's like a a reserve
asset of the government then there's
this development bank that
is owned by the government the
development bank uh
looks more and feels more like a regular
bank that you would see in the united
states but it's owned by the government
at that development bank so not the
reserves of the government but at the
development bank they are basically
creating a 150 million dollar
fund uh they keep referring to it it's
like a trust fund
uh and the purpose of that is they will
seat it with dollars so 150 us dollars
uh they then create a mandate that any
merchant
must accept bitcoin not exclusively so
somebody shows up with dollars
you have to accept the dollars somebody
shows up with bitcoin you have to take
the bitcoin
now it's very similar to the in the
united states if somebody shows up with
dollars you have to accept it right it's
a mandated thing
um it is not necessarily a mandate if
somebody shows up with a different type
of currency depending where you are what
the currency is all that stuff
but in el salvador now dollars in
bitcoin will be mandated to be accepted
by the merchants
some merchants want dollars some
merchants want the bitcoin so the
merchants that want the bitcoin they'll
accept it and they'll hold the bitcoin
the merchants that want dollars will
accept bitcoin if somebody wants to pay
them in bitcoin
and then the government says turn around
and you sell us the
bitcoin and we'll give you dollars so
we'll give you choice as to
what you hold but you have to at least
accept it for
uh for payments and so what that 150
million u.s dollars is there for is
basically that is the
liquidity pool if you will that will be
used to purchase from the merchants
uh once it is uh purchased the
government will hold the bitcoin in the
trust fund or in the development fund so
150 us dollars is eventually going to
get converted to 150 u.s equivalent of
bitcoin
right depending on prices whatever and
uh what's interesting is the
government's basically market-making
and so they are going to maybe make a
little bit of money lose a little bit of
money
over and over and over again i have no
clue how sophisticated this is there's
gonna be technology or is it literally
gonna be like you know
bring your bring your bitcoin type thing
it's like
there's details that still need to kind
of be flushed out here um but
uh strike is one of the companies that
is providing a bunch of technology uh
block stream is another
um and so strikes got some pretty
sophisticated ways to do conversions via
an api and stuff like that so i actually
think it'll be
pretty well done um and the whole idea
is just like now the government says hey
we're gonna make bitcoin legal tender
you as a merchant have to accept it just
like you have to accept dollars
and uh we'll help you de-risk we'll give
you free choice in the back end
let's go well that piece there the the
ability to for a merchant to just
swap it and the government being able to
backstop that that's
really interesting so so that that means
that they're not only
enabling the you know the merchant side
of it but
you know the government's actually going
to put bitcoin on their own balance
sheet
yeah and the way they're interesting and
the way that they're doing it is like
uh it's unique because technically they
can say that they're not putting it on
their balance sheet yet
uh if you make it legal tender though uh
my guess um is that that is the
intention
that they will put it actually on the
balance sheet as well but then they have
this like trust fund and so like is the
trust fund the balance sheet like
technically no but indirectly yes right
in that well it was money off the
balance sheet that went into the trust
fund and therefore the government
controls it
whatever uh but i think that just like
overarching
a nation state is adopting bitcoin yeah
right yeah and we can
debate how sequentially should they do
xyz whatever but like it's legal tender
they're gonna be buying bitcoin from
people with dollars and then now they're
talking about mining
yeah what else do you want from an agent
right yeah
this is like i've i've always thought
and i mean all of us have been thinking
for a long time is like how does this
play out
and like it's literally playing out in
front of us like and the thing is
none of us could have guessed in what
order like you said what sequence
what pattern what method what uh
mechanism would be used to do this so i
actually
i i didn't say anything on the day when
you know jack announced that i was like
yeah okay i just want to see
what it actually means but then after
the call you know after i dug into a
little bit i was like [ __ ] this is
actually
this is actually good so this is what do
you think the ramifications are
like with either other countries uh
individuals corporations
man it i've been saying this for ages
a couple years ago one probably even
maybe longer than a couple like five or
six years ago it was a risk
not to be associated sorry to be
associated with bitcoin right it was a
risk to have some bitcoin
now it's you know quick
more and more rapidly becoming a risk
not to have an association with bitcoin
and that that that game theory change or
that that incentive change
can like create like a spiral effect or
like a really rapid move
uh like the pendulum will swing to the
other end it's kind of what's happening
sort of here in america with the masks
thing right so it's like miami came out
and said all right you know we're not
doing that
and now all of a sudden texas came out
and you know someone else and someone
else
so the pendulum swings back very quickly
and and that kind of momentum
if you're if you're positioned right for
it like there there is huge opportunity
in that momentum and and that's sort of
where this is it so it'll be
it'll be really interesting to see like
i mean we saw the laser eyes already
with a bunch of different
people so so you know we don't know what
that means yet
but i mean i i would hate to be the imf
in central banks right now
oh i i actually don't even know if it's
uh necessarily
combative yet maybe it gets there but
here's a perfect example so
uh we explicitly asked on the twitter
spaces uh there's convening of heads of
state there was the
head of el salvador uh there was nick
carter who is head of
uh the twitterverse uh there was
me jack dorsey and a bunch of other
people
who are the heads of the interwebs and
so we brought all these heads of state
together on the diplomatic call
kidding and when we were all on this
twitter spaces call
uh i can't remember if it was me alex
gladstein
nick whoever asked him somebody
explicitly said
hey have you heard from the imf or from
the united states or governments or
whatever and there was kind of like a uh
offhand yeah i heard about it hold on a
second i'm like doing something
and then other questions got asked and
it almost like didn't get answered so
people started just dming me non-stop
and they were like
hey get an answer for that so i said
look you know apologies for having asked
twice but like
what did they say and the response that
the
president gave was very interesting it
was kind of nonchalant like oh we're
gonna have a meeting like i don't think
it's a big deal
he was like actually this is good for
the united states this is good for some
of these places and so immediately it's
like well
how and one of the things he said that i
thought was fascinating was he said
listen
the united states one of the biggest
problems the united states has with el
salvador
is that a bunch of our citizens keep
going there and illegal immigrating
right and if so we have a bunch of
illegal immigration to the united states
and you want to stop that
the best thing we can do is make our
country a place
that you want to stay that there's
opportunity that there's wealth
generation
um that their safety all this stuff and
this is a great way to do it
and so that was a really really
fascinating thing
to kind of unpack where you start to say
listen
a country that is in the developing
world that many people
you know cite the murder rate or the
lack of economic growth or you know
whatever the thing is
now says we've found a way to be more
prosperous to be more safe to be
uh kind of more beneficial for our
citizens and they're gonna stay here and
by the way we're gonna solve one of your
problems
pretty interesting way to kind of frame
it right i mean that's that's framing
dude we
like the thing is the imf and central
banks don't care about that problem they
don't care about solving that problem
like you know if we've seen anything in
the last 18 to 24 months like
their business model is one of um
you know extracting wealth from others
like so central banks exist not to
produce anything but to extract
so you know
bitcoin is an assault on that kind of a
system like you know
it it it exists it's a peaceful protest
it's a peaceful protest but it's still
an assault on that system like it it
it rips away like it rug pulls
the the raison datra for central
planning
i don't think that it actually is
combative though like that's part of why
i like bitcoin
is it doesn't do anything to
the existing system the existing system
can continue to exist
for example the existing system over the
last 12 months
has done a fantastic job of doing what
they do best implementing their power
doing all this stuff bitcoin has still
succeeded and bitcoin is a beneficiary
of it
but there's no kind of combativeness to
it like bitcoin can actually win
and there's still be coexistence with
the legacy system now the legacy system
as we all
i think agree is going to lose users
but like take yahoo for example
right yahoo was the pinnacle of the
internet it was the front page of the
internet for a long time
today if you see a yahoo email address
or somebody's like oh yahoo's my
homepage there's like a certain framing
there right
of like it's a certain type of person
usually a little bit older all this kind
of stuff
and it's a generalization that's not
always true but
even though younger people have all
moved on to
other websites other things other email
addresses whatever still a remnant
yahoo is one of the largest uh finance
websites for example
in the world yahoo finance is massive
right
and so i think that's similar to what
we're watching here which is like
there's a generational shift for sure
there's going to be some of the older
generations also that transition
uh bitcoin will succeed but i don't
think it's like
10 years from now there's no fiat and
it's all bitcoin not 10 years but on a
longer on a longer time guess what you
think the timeline is
i think 200 years no hell no no i think
it's like
three or four decades so 30 to 40 years
from now
you think that the entire fiat system's
gone uh
more or less yeah i think because here's
what happens it precipitates on the way
out so
so it starts to fall faster and faster
and faster
because what you get is like you get if
there was a definition
collapse basically right so sorry not
reverse collapse you get like
you get a collapse as you get
hyperinflation and hyperinflation is a
confidence thing
it doesn't matter how much money you've
printed it actually is a complete
confidence thing
so when the thing starts to fall apart
and the confidence is lost
that's when the whole thing starts to
completely collapse so
um where like the way this is going to
play out is
this decade is going to be messy as [ __ ]
um
so there'll be there'll be points at
which like i think the next
three or four or five years socially is
going to get even worse like you know
there'll be more restrictions there'll
be more stupidities there'll be
you know desperation on the part of
banks and central banks and all this
sort of stuff to try and
fix things that they've broken and in
the process break them even more
um you know we'll sort of hit some sort
of trough period and then
at the same time like i i call it um i'm
gonna swear now but
pockets of brilliance in a sea of [ __ ]
basically so so there's there'll be all
sorts of crap going on but
the pockets of brilliance will be
represented by
kind of things like that are going in el
salvador etc now
the reason i say this is because there
is only one way for large nation states
or central banks to exist
and that is to blanket tax
or to print money in the absence of
those two tools
they actually can't fund themselves a a
government a nation-state level
government or a central bank is a
bankrupt institution
and what bitcoin does is that it
eliminates the capacity for a bankrupt
institution to
exist because you can't tax
the bitcoin forcefully like what you
need to do is you need to provide a
service
uh in order to get someone's bitcoin um
or you need to
well so that's the only way or you need
to beat them over the head with a club
and take their private key but
you know if you hit them too high
they're not gonna remember it so it's
like
it it changes the dynamics of how
societies should function i call it
moving from an
overlord subject relationship which is
the relationship we have with
governments and central banks today
moving to a customer and service
provider relationship
but through necessity that means
jurisdictions are going to have to get
smaller they cannot remain large
because you can't you cannot
economically
you cannot feasibly economically run a
large
region um profitably so so
in the absence of being able to print
money and keep yourself in business
fraudulently by borrowing from the
future by leaching from people and by
taxing
you're screwed you have to provide a
service and you can't do that at scale
like it has to happen
at a smaller scale that's why you know a
lot of people talk about ief vr and
bitcoin will co-exist
they will not like for a while they will
but when
when the thing starts falling off like
it it'll be like you know bitcoins is
black hole
and you know we're getting closer and
the fiat system is getting closer and
closer
to the black hole but once it hits the
event horizon it's gonna [ __ ] yeah i
think there's just different times
you're talking about right i'm talking
about 10 years from now you're talking
about
40 50 years from now i'm talking yeah a
couple more decades so i think
this decade is where we get close to the
thing next decade
is probably where we start to reach the
event horizon somewhere in there and
like 2040 onwards
like you don't have fiat anymore there's
absolutely no need for it
so if we think about this whole idea of
uh coexistence for some period of time i
think what else salvador is super
interesting
but what should other countries do just
do they immediately run and take the
playbook from el salvador
and basically implement it in their
countries or is there different ways to
do it 100
take take the [ __ ] playbook and do
whatever variant you need like
this is so this is where the
the small countries that have been
traditionally like backwards or you know
broke or broken um so so my parents come
from macedonia
um i i was there last year and like i
you know whenever people sit here and
talk about like oh you know communism is
great i'm like
just just just go to eastern europe for
a bit and like go specifically to
macedonia like where there's
no soul left in the country like
everyone's like all the youth has left
anyone with a brain has left anyone with
ambition has left it's like sort of
left like a husk of a nation and and
like
it's it's broken nothing works
everyone's
defeated and you know it's dead but
those places potentially have an
opportunity
to do something well it's just the
developing world or those that are
broken nations they have the opportunity
to leapfrog the
current uh kind of leaders it's exactly
what we see technologies the innovator's
dilemma and the
powers that be uh they're sitting cushy
and so the
upstarts the challengers they're the
ones who have the opportunity exactly
and but they they have also the extra
opportunity that they're small
so they have less space to manage and
less [ __ ] to deal with
i mean some places have a lot of crap to
deal with like you know with
you know a completely broken
infrastructure but the smaller you are
the quicker you can actually evolve
into what jurisdictions are going to
look like
in the new world like they're not going
to look like what they look like today
is there something about a smaller
country also just has less bureaucracy
and there's usually kind of more
centralized power in the country and
therefore uh they're
they can move quicker like el salvador
went four days from announcement to uh
having
its legal tender look that absolutely
helps the the thing is
some countries don't have smaller
bureaucracy like so so maybe in el
salvador it's it's
interesting because he's got you know
he's got some strength there
um whereas like in a dumbass country
like macedonia
you actually have more bureaucracy than
america for like 1 million people it's
ridiculous so
so so that kind of depends but yeah
definitely having
having a director or having you know
dictated whatever the word is like
having someone to to lead that
and and point um that of course is gonna
help what's fascinating to me is what
the el salvadorian
or with the salvadorian uh situation is
uh everyone's like oh he's a dictator
he's this he's whatever
i'm not an expert in salvadorian
politics don't want to be
uh but i've never seen a dictator hold a
vote
and 25 of the congress vote against them
like they just get killed right like you
don't mean like like
and again dictators all around the world
bad people the whole nine yards uh
but to me it's just i think there's
a lot of politicalization of this in el
salvador so therefore uh
people outside will never understand it
when you move to some of these other
countries like macedonia for example
i don't i couldn't tell you who the
leader is i couldn't tell you what the
political structure is i can tell you
what the process is
i couldn't tell you if i literally
couldn't even tell you is it communist
is it democratic is it whatever
again that's just because i think most
people are worried about where they live
right and so if we're gonna play this
game of uh every time a country says hey
we're interested in technology we're
interested in bitcoin we're interested
in uh you know kind of a new path
forward
and we all try to scramble to become
experts on those political environments
i think we have a really hard time
and so instead if you simply just say
listen it doesn't matter
if it's a democratic leader or a
dictator
if they adopt this as money within their
country
it prevents them from being able to do
what we see other dictators do with fiat
systems right
that comes back to what we said earlier
bitcoin naturally subverts fear
like bit bitcoin actually the whole
bitcoin invention is a subversion
and a a um a forking of the road
from the fiat path that we're on like i
i think it's so important that
you know the whole aliens thing and you
know the great filter right
i think if there is any other societies
that
you know hadn't made it through the
great filter they blew themselves up by
either dropping a nuke on themselves
getting whacked by an asteroid or
through destroying their society through
fiat
like because i think fiat was is a
necessary progression that all human
species have to go through like all
all homo sapien all sentient species
like we we
naturally like money is the thing that
permeates all of existence right you
cannot do what you do i kind of do what
i do
and we can't you know collaborate and
interact without some sort of
uh mechanism to exchange human action
right that's effectively what money is
so money's or
money will exist from the from the
beginning of time until the end of time
so long as the sentient species exists
the only thing that changes is the
object that we use
uh for money now we have come to the
point now where
we had to go through salt seashells
cattle
blah blah blah you know gold uh
paperback gold
you know the fiat abomination and all of
that but when you when you look at it on
a longer
time scale like me and francis pulley
were talking about this it's like
when we look back on this if we make it
through the great filter now like if we
actually
can measure human action effectively and
if we can restructure the system such
that
positive actions uh spiral upwards
and negative actions actually correct
right so at the moment we
cover up negative axes so if you do
something dumb it just gets socialized
to everyone else right so it that
actually rots the system
but you know on a bitcoin standard you
know you can actually move upwards you
can move downwards which is really
important
and downward motion gets corrected very
quickly and upward motion spirals so
in that kind of a thing we have the
opportunity to sort of
uh progress society now on a
on a long enough time scale like we'll
look back on this thousands of years
from now we'll say all right
the the um the inventions that made
uh homo sapiens of humans in whatever
capacity we're going to be
in like intergalactic species was fire
bitcoin teleportation like honestly
internet electricity all this other
stuff
was invented for bitcoin like that
something nuts right
i know it does all right that's how big
all that's how big bitcoin is going to
be for all of those things
like what is the biggest critique of
that view
uh my own personal critique no like it
if if you had to think of the critics
what would they say is like why you're
wrong
um bitcoin's slow like i think the only
critique
would come from someone who doesn't
believe money is this important
everything stops without money you you
can't like you don't have
the capacity to do anything and how do
you think about like the inflation and
all of the
recent announcements so we're recording
this uh
the consumer goods uh prices just got
announced five percent
increase uh it's the most since the
global financial crisis
um if you look at uh all sorts of other
metrics
you know through uh may i think in the
start of 2021
inflation is at like 2.7 percent uh
and likely to continue to go higher like
does all of that just feed into this
is that a response to bitcoin is bitcoin
just a beneficiary of what they were
already gonna do
that's all breadcrumbs that fell off the
side of the table like bitcoin has such
a larger impact like all of these things
is
we're just playing games we're a bunch
of like
again when you spread out the time scale
like fiat
is a 150 200 year experiment
on a far far far far longer time time
span
and all we're doing is we're we're
we're placating ourselves so i wrote a
recent article um so i'm taking jordan
peterson's 12 rules for life
um and then i'm writing about bitcoin
through the lens of each rule so i'm up
to chapter two now oh um
chapter three but chapter two was about
uh bitcoin chaos and order and
and in there i talk about how uh
you know you've got the study of matter
and the study of what matters so the
study of matter is like empirical
sciences physics etc and the study of
what matters is things like philosophy
economics trade-offs you know
psychology etc now what we've tried to
do is because the study of matter has
been so
effective um over the last couple
hundred years particularly with the
with the um formalization of the study
of matter and
sciences you know with the renaissance
we have now tried to take that
process and apply it to everything else
so we've tried to deconstruct economics
which is not a study of matter like
economics is the study of
individual human beings who make actions
that are different at every single
moment in time like you cannot
replicate an economic uh period like we
can't take
what happened last week and do it again
this week like we can't press the rewind
button so
trying to distill something like
economics into an empirical study
is completely mindless so doing all
these things like measuring cpi and like
trying to like figure all this stuff out
it's all vanity metrics like none of it
actually really matters and then on top
of that
they go around and they're like okay
well with cpi let's just take
this out let's take this out let's take
this out and it's a
it's a fake metric designed to
to make the to give the model
some semblance of sense like so they're
trying to fit reality to the model
instead of the model to reality it's the
opposite way around
and so so we're literally like we're
driving a car
with a fake dashboard with a fake
speedometer
with a fake everything and we think it's
okay
because like you know the dashboard says
we're driving you know 60
miles an hour but in reality there's a
[ __ ] wall there
and we're driving 200 miles an hour
right into a wall but we feel good about
it
what's up guys bang bang i hope you're
enjoying this conversation but before we
go any further i want to quickly tell
you about today's sponsor
blockfi blockfish got four different
financial products for crypto investors
you can deposit crypto and earn up to
8.6 apy
in an interest-bearing account you can
deposit crypto and take out a us dollar
loan against your crypto collateral
you can use their cryptocurrency
exchange and have no trading fees
or you can get a new bitcoin rewards
credit card it's a normal credit card
that when you swipe you get bitcoin back
rather than cash back or airline miles
i'm an investor in the business and a
very happy user
i think you will be too when you go to
blockfy.com
pomp again blockfy.com go check it out
and let me know what you think
all right let's get back into this
conversation i hope you enjoy it what
about all the other cryptocurrencies
other than bitcoin um i would say
at best they're um they're attempts
by people who have no idea why bitcoin
exists
um so bitcoin is a system of rules not
rulers
right so so these guys are like oh so
bitcoin is about sending money to each
other for free
no that's not what it is but so so they
go and you know roll their own version
of it
and they become their own rulers of
their own money
so so at best it's like naive and stupid
at worst i think it's a state level
attack
um on bitcoin so this is an interesting
attack vector and breedlove and i were
talking about this
um a couple months back about
the state and central banks and
governments and all that sort of stuff
like you know grouped in
into that sort of sphere will continue
to realize that they can't do anything
about bitcoin
like they'll throw fud they'll throw
like oh the fbi hacked it you know like
the
the energies is gonna boil the oceans
like every year it's boiling theirs
my favorite is senator warren what what
did citizen warren say recently
yesterday she had some real good ones
please tell me at least
one i mean basically uh bitcoin consumes
more energy than
some countries and therefore we need to
uh
you know basically regulate it control
it get rid of it whatever nonsense she
was saying
we should ban clothes dryers because
that actually consumes more energy than
bitcoin but anyway
my favorite is christmas lights yes
christmas lights thank you we're gonna
cancel christmas yeah we should
definitely cancel christmas because it
uses up too much energy um
so so they'll throw everything at it but
they can't beat it
they can't stop it um so i think
the best angle of attack like if i was a
government
i would go in and i would start
supporting something
like an ethereum or something like
kadano or something like or whatever
like one of these other um [ __ ] coins
and
all you have to do at that stage so
bitcoin is enforced at the level of the
individual the node operator
enforces the rules of bitcoin now i
enforce those rules of bitcoin for
myself
and i do it voluntarily and
i come into consensus with everybody
else who's enforcing the same rules
that's what makes bitcoin so powerful
whereas with all of these other networks
it's not enforced at the level
individual there's a foundation there's
a group there's an institution there's a
you know there's a coalition there's a
governance structure
that decides how this thing runs now
if i was the government i would be
becoming friendly with the joe lubins
and the vitaliks of the world
give them as much free reign to sort of
hoodwink everyone into this idea of
decentralization and you know competing
with bitcoin
proof of stake is like the perfect like
proof of stake is central banking
of course that's what it is so you know
these guys are going to move over to
that
and then whoever runs the largest chunk
of stake
calls the shots and if i was the
government i'd come in and say all right
well this is how we're going to run
things now we're going to issue the the
imf dollar on ethereum or whatever
well it's there's two different things
one they could just spend a bunch of
fiat and become the largest
you know staker right uh or they could
nationalize it
or they just they don't even they can do
it behind the scenes man
like you know if if if i'm someone who's
been trying to pull the strings
at the imf or the central bank or
whatever these you know three-letter
soup organizations are i'll just go to
dinner with
vitalik and say this is how it's gonna
happen um
doesn't matter what you say and you know
you'll you'll start to see it back what
do you think his reaction would be i
don't know vitalik
so uh but i think that i want to caveat
this with uh
it's obvious he's very intelligent i
mean like scary intelligent
um and i'm going to
always put for people i don't know like
i assume that they're doing what they
believe is like the best thing so like a
good actor um
and if they do something that is
misplaced
like don't assign malice where ignorance
could be the explanation
right so from that lens like
just game theory it out somebody from
the existing system comes and sits down
with
five of the largest ethereum holders and
says we want you to do acts like what do
they do
what could they do what can they do they
can't do [ __ ]
in terms of they can't change the system
or they can't say no
they can't say no that they they can't
say
no that that's the problem like i mean
we all know what happens to people who
disagree with you know these large-scale
organizations like i mean you know
you've got people with a lot more balls
than um
vitalik and all of that that have you
know had their countries blown up taken
over blah blah i was literally just
gonna ask you do you think that it's
more risky from a nation-state
vantage point uh to be the heads of a
country that tries to get off the dollar
or
to be uh somebody who not just ethereum
but just one of these things that the
government decides
hey we're going to try to leverage this
for our benefit and you don't want to do
it
oh um
i still think it's worse to be the
nation state head probably
yeah probably it's it's probably more
dangerous to be the nation state head
but yeah
but here's the thing like you know you
mentioned before you know
vitalik smith everyone thought uh
elizabeth holmes was really
highly intelligent and and i mean to an
expert she was yeah fair enough exactly
um so so like i actually think uh
vitalik is um
is not so smart i think he's highly
naive i think he's um he's
like you don't think he's smart at all
no not really because i mean
because i understand what he talks about
dude i understand what he talks about
and he just talks in [ __ ] circles
like that's the thing like he actually
doesn't make sense what do you okay so
here's an interesting question
uh we may disagree on this what what do
you
disagree with him on or what do you
think he's wrong his first principles
so like you know what does that mean so
the first principles
he doesn't take a first principles
approach to building things
okay so like you know as an example um
he is still of the opinion that uh and
from the beginning like you know he
he got sort of laughed at when uh his
suggestions about bitcoin you know we
should do smart contracts on the base
layer blah blah so
so he's a bit of a he's a naive kid
who thinks that bitcoin and money is
just some sort of toy that we can play
with
um and because he couldn't get his way
in bitcoin
um because all these suggestions were
stupid he went off and built his own toy
um and because he's intelligent enough
to sound intelligent and because he
looks the part
um you know a lot of people buy into the
kool-aid idea like you know they sort of
take the kool-aid and they're like oh
you know he's the boy genius blah blah
and you know you ask someone uh to
explain what vitalik's actually talking
about in a podcast they'll be like
i don't know but it sounds smart um so
i'll listen to him so
so it's like people don't actually
know what the [ __ ] he's talking about
half the time and when you actually
listen to the things he says like
half of the things are contradictory
like half of his statements give me an
example
well his thing about proof of work like
he thinks proof of work
is inefficient proof of work is the most
efficient
mechanism for um doing anything in life
i mean if you're an artist what are you
doing proof of work if you go to the gym
what are you doing proof of work like
proof of work permeates all of existence
proof of stake is a human-created
aberration
in which a group of people want to have
an advantage over another group of
people
like that's the first principles
approach to proof-of-work whereas
he's trying to take some high-level
abstracted view of
let's tweak some variables up the top
here and we can create a
game theoretically sound system that
doesn't matter like what is missing is
the actual first principles
of why proof of work actually functions
so to me that tells me
he actually doesn't get it um so he he's
completely missed the point is it
possible that he understands that but
thinks that the bigger
benefit is the trade-off between um
getting efficient like energy
uh consumption let's say that was his
thing right he wanted to get more
efficient energy consumption
and he was willing to trade off the
decentralization or the proof of work
value all that stuff
because it's not more efficient in terms
of energy it's not proof of stake is
actually inefficient
okay explain so okay let's think about
the the
greatest example of proof-of-stake at
the moment you just got real excited so
i'm excited i know all right let's go
so so proof of stake uh represents
the way the world functions at the
moment right like he who has
decides and decides for everyone else
not just for himself
right um so what what that creates
through necessity is layers of
bureaucracy
the biggest damage we do to the
environment as a species
is not the use of fossil fuels like
fossil fuels is actually a direct
extraction of energy
from you know something that existed
beforehand
and use of that energy so things like
i'm going to go on a slight tangent here
and then i'll come back in
things like you know renewable energies
and solar panels and wind and all this
sort of stuff and this is a whole
different rabbit hole but
they're actually less energy efficient
than fossil fuels and they do more
damage to the environment because the
amount of energy consumption that's
required to build these things
is never actually paid back you know
when you count up maintenance when you
count up all the other things
and the fact that they're subsidized
through the
taxation or creation of money what that
actually means is
money represents human resources it
represents natural and human resources
combined so when you're actually
leeching money from one thing to
subsidize something else
the actual real environmental cost of
that is a lot higher than
what you think it is on paper so
all of this sort of renewable energy
stuff is all like
one big mess because it actually is not
helping us like if we put all of that
energy time and effort into making
the extraction of fossil fuels more
efficient i'm gonna do a podcast next
week with alex epstein
we we would have like
cars would be more efficient um power
plants would be more efficient like all
of the things
that we take for granted today in an
energy rich society would be way more
efficient
but coming back to um so energy use so
energy use is correlated with um and you
know
it i think is extremely causal with like
um
uh human prosperity right like you know
the the more
we do the better we do the more energy
exactly
so that's not where the problem is
the problem is is all in all the wastage
so when you think about
what is required to maintain a system
which is built on proof of stake so
government
central banking all this other stuff the
layers of bureaucracy
the waste like you know for the us to
function you need the military
industrial complex
you need the whole banking system you
need wall street think about all the
buildings the the unnecessary people
that are hired
all of the crap that goes in there like
you know with governments as well like i
mean the masks thing is a perfect
example
30 billion disposable masks get
dumped every month all because of a
moronic mandate like
all of these misallocations of resources
all of that stuff
basically we're probably like if i had
to just take a number out of my ass like
60 70 80 percent of the energy we use is
wasted on stupidity
so the biggest impact bitcoin is going
to have is because it eliminates
the wastage we will actually become a
far more efficient
society consumption goes down like
we we blindly consume [ __ ] that we don't
need because
the incentive is to spend like you know
gdp gross domestic product
is not a measure of production it's a
measure of consumption it's it's
everything's [ __ ] asked backwards
so tying that to proof of stake
is that that kind of a system
trends towards bureaucracy it trends
towards waste
because it's not tethered to proof of
work
so proof-of-work drives efficiency
because it's
tied or it's tethered to the second law
of thermodynamics that's actually what
creates efficiency
when you create these abstractions you
move away from reality
and you don't know what you're doing and
you waste
and waste is actually what destroys the
environment destroys resources
destroys energy waste energy etc so is
it fair to say you think proof of stake
if i had to categorize your argument it
is
one uh those who are rich get to call
the shots which is
a direct uh kind of comparison or
evolution from what we already have
and then two is proof of work drives a
level of efficiency because the
less percentage of the energy that is
consumed is used for wasteful purposes
versus proof of stake uh would end up
being high waste
regardless of the total energy
consumption correct proof of stake will
turn to waste it'll trend that way in
the beginning it may not
you know in the beginning i mean you
know proof of stake
you know the stake is represented by an
amount of capital now
capital do you think they're actually
going to do the update i
actually heard there's some more delays
now so it's like now it's 2024
apparently
um because they have to build a
scaffolding that sort of uh sits below
so then you need to stake
a bunch of eth or some [ __ ] like that on
um on the scaffolding
and then you can't take that off so that
so it's like it's stuck there
until you know that's sort of ready and
then they have to merge everything
across
dude ain't gonna happen for another
couple years
does it ever happen probably not and who
really cares
i think it happens i agree with you that
it takes a longer time
i mean at this point like the whole the
whole thing we're trying to do here with
bitcoin is we're trying to transform the
world from
one in which any authority has the
capacity to decide for somebody else
like i don't want some bureaucrat
who's never met me to decide what i
should do with my money
with my life with my decisions or any of
that sort of stuff so bitcoin ushers in
a world of
sovereign individualism that doesn't
mean every man for himself like that
this is something we need to sort of
like
clarify because whenever people hear
this it's like so what everyone's going
to live in their own cardboard box or in
their own bunker and like sort of
war that's not what happens human beings
like do you have friends
of course you do i mean i hope i have
friends like
what do friends do do we are we forced
to have friends no like we we find
people that we align with that we have
similar values with
and we create these communities that
they're emerging they bottom up
and and so so bitcoin enables a world in
which
we can actually do that voluntarily and
by our own volition as opposed to
being forced into these you know group
identity politics and all this sort of
[ __ ]
you know by morons who think they know
better for everybody else
because they don't have any discipline
in their own lives so it's like that you
know
like a politician or a bureaucrat or a
central banker or someone who
like doesn't have any capacity to
have control in their own life so they
want to control everyone else's life
and all we're seeing with crypto and all
this stuff is just the replication of
that
but just in a digital form like i don't
we don't need
a group of nerds to replace a group of
bankers
like you know they're the same thing
it's just one's just a younger version
of it
i don't think i've ever heard anyone say
replacing the bankers with the nerds
uh but proof of stake for sure whoever
has
the most gets it what about the critique
of that that says well that just means
you have more skin in the game
and therefore because you have skin in
the game you actually protect the
network
um i guess
that is a critique so you've got
more skin in the game and you protect
the network that
in a way i agree with right um because
like i've actually said this me and
glad's team were discussing this about
voting i was like you know
if if you don't pay taxes you shouldn't
get a vote basically um
and and what that actually trends
towards is voting
just actually being an economic decision
so you abolish voting all together and
the only voting
that anyone partakes in is uh what you
buy like your
your purchase is your vote so you know
you you vote for the car you want to
buy by you know buying it but um you
know
in this sense the problem we've got with
it
is that yes you've got more skin in the
game and you know yes you should
have the right to to make the decision
but money
how the money functions should not be
anyone's
decision it should be enforced at the
level of the individual
and it like you know that there's a joke
which is you know
god gave humanity money and he [ __ ] up
like
i'm paraphrasing it's something
different but that's kind of what it is
right so like
money should be outside of all of our
hands no matter who's got the biggest
the lowest stake like the rules of money
should sit completely outside of
anybody's hands so
that uh gold would fit in there gold
kind of fits in there exactly because
it's it's a metal we can't change
the chemical properties of the metal so
so it exists as that
gold just has physical properties that
make it
uh prone to being held in large
quantities
by certain authorities so the whole idea
of sound when it's outside the system
you can't create more of it uh and
therefore that makes it that quote
unquote sound money it's just that
bitcoin's a digital version gold's
physical version
correct but bitcoin actually so so
remember before i was saying money is
this
thing that permeates all of existence so
so money is like a meta idea or meta
energy or
information at its very like purest form
bitcoin makes money information again so
you know bitcoins like slogan should be
make money great again like that's sort
of the um
the thing so it puts it out of reach of
all of us
so none of us can play god with anybody
else so so again like
the idea of having extra skin in the
game to call the shots
makes sense but not for the
the the mechanism via which human action
is measured right and that's money like
that's the most important thing
once we've got that out of the way we
can do everything else like we move into
a world of and this is
you know maybe another unpopular opinion
is like we don't need decentralization
decentralization
has one reason to exist and that is for
censorship resistance
and we need censorship resistance on
money
all the other stuff we can compete our
way into better
products and services and so i think the
future that bitcoin gives us
is not a future of all these
decentralized products and decentralized
financing all this other crap
that that's all noise in the short term
in the long term what will happen is
we will have competing companies
competing ideas competing entrepreneurs
all this sort of stuff
competing their way to better products
and services
because they can't get a they can't get
regulatory arbitrage
they can't grow big and then socialize
their losses when they [ __ ] up
they can't get excess capital that the
little guys can't get because they're
close enough to the monetary spigot so
all of that stuff gets removed and we
actually live in a world where we get
this
dynamic equilib sorry this dynamic
inequality so we'll still have the 80 20
going like we'll still have larger
companies and smaller companies
but we'll actually be competing in a way
that is not unfair today like if i want
to create a twitter
competitor twitter gets access to public
money
to 401k money to like all this money
there is not a chance in hell i could
ever compete with them
but in a world in which all of that
funny money doesn't exist
where we have to compete on merit i
could compete with a twitter
so so so we start to actually we don't
level out the playing field
but we create an 80 20 instead of a 99.9
0.01
and that's like we live in a world of
unnatural inequality today
whereas bitcoin will sort of bring in
natural inequality
and it'll be dynamic as opposed to
static
talk about amber and what you guys are
doing lately all right so
amber is still only in australia um so
things suppose surprise surprise take
longer to um
to do but the app is really stable in
australia
um it is the best way to buy bitcoin in
ours
uh we actually introduced amber black so
this is the bomb so
you can you just pay membership fee and
you can buy and sell as much bitcoin as
you want there's no fees
uh but more importantly you get like a
series of cool features so you can like
auto withdraw to your cold storage
um and then my favorite button is uh the
auto buy the dip
so you can um you can set an if this
then that function so like if bitcoin
falls x percent
uh in 24 hours buy me this much bitcoin
so that's like
the best uh button ever so you can like
you can stack on normal
dca um and like while you're sleeping if
the price of bitcoin dips you know you
can
extra stack so that's that's where the
product is at the moment
um next step for us is in the next
couple weeks
we're going to be rolling out the beta
for the us so you know if anyone wants
to try it out
dm us i think the the handle is at
the amber app with the th at the front
so the amber app
um but dms or follow us or whatever and
um
and we'll get you going on the on the
beta so we'll
when we land in the us it's only going
to be amber basic so amber black won't
come straight away
um we just got to get you know grease up
all the uh all the gears and stuff and
make sure it's all functioning
so we'll do that very shortly thereafter
we're going to look at uh introducing a
an amber debit card so the whole point
will be to save your bitcoin
spend your fiat right and so so we'll
link that
strategy absolutely like that's what
everyone should do like my whole goal is
actually to build mini michael sailors
inside the app so that way
you build up like i always say this when
people say oh so what's different to
amber than like a
then a coin base i'm like well coinbase
wants you to trade
like they literally want you it's a [ __ ]
coin casino that's
what i call it and amber like what we
want you to do is build enduring wealth
uh in the form of bitcoin and you know
everything is designed for you to
accumulate bitcoin so it's a bitcoin
accumulation app it's not a trading app
and when you do that hey you might have
some fiat in there you know you might
have topped up your account you know i
want people to use it as a bank account
but also as their you know bitcoin
savings account and then you know we're
gonna
uh integrate uh lightning and uh layer
one
uh a bitcoin wallet in there so that way
you can actually interact with the
bitcoin world
and you'll you know with your debit card
and then depending on which jurisdiction
you'll you'll have a functional
fiat account in there so you can receive
your pay you can send money so that way
you're connected to both worlds
and it'll act as this bridge um over
time and then we'll
link the um the the bitcoin account with
the fiat account
through being able to borrow fiat
against your bitcoin
so um in that sense you've got like a
constant credit line
inside the app where you never have to
sell your bitcoin if you need some fiat
emergency
borrow 500 bucks against your bitcoin
you know it locks it up in there in a
multi-sig
you know we won't really hypothecate we
won't do any of that and then that way
you can
spend so that way you've actually got
like a a bitcoin bank in your pocket
that talks to both worlds so you know if
you're in el salvador
and you need to buy something use
lightning
if you're in america or in australia use
your debit card
like you you'll have the options and you
can take amber with you anyway so that's
sort of the plan
but in the short term next step us and
then we'll look
at other places and this is pretty much
all retail right if you're
if you're an individual this is for you
100 100
what has been the biggest surprise over
the last 12 months in terms of building
it
the biggest surprise the biggest
surprise or biggest challenge
both okay biggest challenge has been
getting good devs man
like you know good product people so so
what's hard in in the bitcoin space is
you you get
one of two things you know you get
people who are like hardcore bitcoin is
really really really really get bitcoin
but they haven't had the experience in
like sort of building tech right or
building a tech company
so so you know you sort of got one side
lacking then on the other side you get
like people who had loads of experience
building products
building tech doing all that stuff but
they don't get bitcoin so so like
trying to find the unicorn that gets
both that's that's
that's a real challenge and you know
we're on the hunt for
for people particularly the best huh for
the best
exactly we're on the hunt for the best
like we we need we need bitcoin
product unicorns so so that's sort of uh
that piece surprise wise i mean
i don't know i think i haven't been
actually probably one thing is just like
the the level of stupidity of some of
the legacy financial institutions that
we
like deal with back in australia like i
won't name any names here but like one
of the partners we're working with
has an upper limit on volume i was like
i'm trying to give you more money i'm
literally trying to give you more
customers
and you charge me per customer so i'm
like literally trying to give you and
they're like sorry we can't accept it
i was like what kind of an industry like
operates like that so why do they do
that it's like a fraud prevention or
something there's some risk
thing but like we actually have less of
a default rate
than a gym so like like but but we're in
a
higher risk category so it's like it
just this is again like a ramification
of the fiat world instead of
uh you know the market deciding
you know which is you know the market
says that we're a safer product
than your gym down around the corner the
regulator says that we're
a much higher risk and therefore should
not be allowed to direct debit more than
a certain amount it's it's complete
madness
so that's the surprise it's fascinating
to me
how uh backwards it seems sometimes
dude it's it's sometimes there's good
reason but
also sometimes maybe not the thing is
a lot of the times the reason that
started back here upstream
it was a good brain fart like oh you
know we should do this
the problem is is when it's mandated as
a blanket solution to something
what happens is all regulations end up
uh
being designed such that it's harder for
legitimate people to do anything because
like in order to stop a bad actor with a
regulation or a rule
you have to blanket everyone so you have
to basically screw everyone over
but then the bad actor all they do is
just figure out a way around the
regulation anyway so
what you've done is you haven't stopped
the bad actor you've actually inhibited
all the good actors
that's why regulations don't work like
that's why bureaucrats just need to get
the [ __ ] out of the way
and let us innovate because the fact
that there's more good actors is will
out compete them but we're getting
handicapped the good guys are getting
handicapped
and the bad guys are just doing what
they want to do anyway so this is why
none of that stuff works
i think that the system is messed up and
it will get changed
i didn't know you thought that i mean
yeah it's just
the incentive is to have those in power
keep the system in place and for those
not in power to change it
well of course i mean that that's always
been the case i actually just think that
this time
it's gonna be the greatest shift that's
ever happened in humanity like
literally this if we if bitcoin doesn't
win
like if bitcoin doesn't break the state
which i think we've already right
won but by the way but if bitcoin
doesn't we are going to either blow
ourselves up
or we're going to become like a big
collectivist dystopia
in which like you know ubia and all this
sort of stuff what it does is it
actually
rips the soul out of humanity like again
macedonia is a great example is
you know in order to equalize society in
order to equalize humans
you can't force people upwards you
actually but you can force them down
and and that's what happens and and you
get that through force but you also get
it through the the maligned incentive
of if you work harder than i do
but we get the same thing what are you
going to think you'll be like
[ __ ] this guy i'm going to work less but
then as you work less then i'm going to
be like
man he's working less enough so i'm
going to work less and you get this
downward spiral
and that's effective what's happening so
when you like
when you look at society people are
going to start getting free money just
to sort of be placated so that they
don't go out and riot
but at the same time you know you get
this sort of equalization effect that
you know everyone's the same and we're
all equal all in this together like
we're [ __ ] not but you know
apparently you know the state
likes to say that we are so as we do
that we actually
kill the spirit of overachievers we kill
the spirit of the 20
who do 80 of the effort and in doing so
we hollow out
society and we make it weaker so so like
we're getting
weakness through safety instead of
getting strength through freedom
and and that they're two divergent paths
and
you know bitcoin is a counter to that
but
you know if it doesn't win we we end up
in a world
in which like things get worse and worse
and worse and worse like we erode the
capital that we've
spent millennia building um people get
more and more empty
um you know the the whole waf you'll
have nothing you'll have no privacy and
you'll be happy you know
like staring into the camera like i
swear i'll be happy um
and like that that's sort of the the
future that we're moving into which
conspiracy theories aside like it
doesn't even need a conspiracy theory to
no they're saying it like that but even
beyond them saying it like
they actually think it's a good idea
like of course i
i'm a big believer that most people who
do dumb things don't think that they're
bad people and they don't think that
what they're doing is wrong
they're just literally dumb people
correct and and and the problem is
that the dumbest of the dumb are the
bureaucrats who are actually deciding
where resources should go
how people should operate what people
should think what they should be taught
at school
what they should put in their bodies
like i was that was just the best meme
the other day
the the belgian health minister you know
like the one that looks like jabba the
hutt and there was this other guy who's
like a personal trainer
who didn't want to get the vaccine so
one of them has a health passport and
the other one doesn't
and like i was looking at that i'm like
man like
so it's just wild right
and unless unless bitcoin wins
we're gonna be living this sort of
twilight zone
disaster and and that doesn't bode well
for the human species
like it really doesn't bode well like at
some point we'll wreck ourselves
like either the energy grid will fall
apart and what a lot of people don't
know and i don't want to get two
doomsdays here
doomsday-ish here but as we start to
like do this moronic push to like you
know eliminate
uh fossil fuels and all this sort of
stuff like california's already a
disaster right
like we're gonna break things that were
built
that we don't even know why they were
built in the first place and
like people don't realize how like
interconnected
especially modern society is and how
fragile it is like you break one chunk
of the supply chain
things get really really bad really
really quickly like food breaks down
energy breaks down heat breaks down like
we saw it in texas last year like really
briefly or if it was early this year or
whatever it was but
that's a bad place um and bitcoin is the
only thing i think that exists today
that really
has a chance of counteracting that and
that's where i get annoyed
you know with all the crapto people and
all the blockchain people like we've got
this thing here
that fundamentally changes the base
incentives of society like
if you remember from sovereign
individual like the whole thesis about
uh changing the returns on violence
right we move away like
by lowering the cost of defense and
increasing the cost of attack
you actually change human behavior you
change how society functions
but more importantly what bitcoin does
is it actually transforms the
individual's relationship
with three things with energy with their
own time
which includes you know their
relationship with their own future and
with natural resources
so what that means is like we actually
start to have a lower time preference
and more of a respect for the things
that we have
because we actually have wealth you know
we can save we're more
we're more discerning about the way we
spend and
you start to create a better individual
and when you create a better individual
you make the world better and that's the
genesis of the bitcoin fixes this meme
so that grassroots foundational shift
what that does is it gives us tracks
that don't lead off the cliff like at
the moment all we're doing with
crypto crypto blockchain fintech
government
politics like all this [ __ ] is we're
fighting over
which person is driving the train that's
gone right off the [ __ ] cliff
bitcoin says here's a new track this
one's going to a nice like green pasture
like let's go on this one and that's
what bitcoiners have realized and we're
like
the [ __ ] are you idiots arguing over the
train wreck for you you're literally
gonna
run off a cliff and you're trying to
keep us all on the train you're not
letting us off
like we are actively exiting and we're
jumping on a different train
and that's the theory i think that's how
it works
where can we send people to find you on
the internet uh well
um i used to be on at alex vetsky
at twitter so we need to find a way to
get my arse back on there but
at the moment i'm ghost of svetsky on
twitter
okay um but if you if you search my
surname s-v-e-t-s-k-i you'll find me on
medium uh what else do i do oh actually
i've got a podcast apparently uh called
the wake up podcast so
you know i've got like lots of broad
guests we go into philosophy psychology
energy
like we're gonna do carnival like all
sorts of random stuff so so there
um and then check out amber.app um
to to keep an eye on what we're doing
with um
with amber and when we're bringing it to
the us and stuff amber.app and then
ghost of svetsky
on twitter hopefully the real one will
come back at some point yeah
awesome thank you so much for doing this
we'll definitely do it again in the
future absolutely brother thank you